le studio québécois de jeux vidéo bid
different Games à obtenir les droits
exclusifs planétaires de l'image et de
la marque de Charlie Chaplin des jeux
vidéo mettant en vedette le célèbre
acteur seront produits et commercialisés
en dès 2023 Yves durant et musée au
graphe et co-fondateur du studio de jeux
québécois bidyfriends bonsoir Monsieur
Durand
monsieur alors dites-nous comment vous
avez réussi à obtenir les droits d'un si
grand personnage qui a transcendé les
cultures et le temps
oui effectivement on pourrait dire que
c'est le résultat d'une longue histoire
familiale puisque depuis des jours
plusieurs années nous étions déjà en
relation avec les ayants droits les
ailes Chaplin il faut comprendre que ce
sont les enfants en même du cinéaste
Charlie Chaplin qui le lui avec son
dernier mariage qui sont qui constituent
le conseil d'administration de la
société qui gère les toits et qui
s'assurent que du respect de l'héritage
moral et légal de l'oeuvre de leur père
nous sommes les concepteurs du musée de
Champion's World qui a été créé en 2016
en Suisse et cela nous a amené à
développer pendant plusieurs années une
relation de proximité avec ses enfants
c'est parce qu'on se connaissait c'est
parce qu'on a établit cette historique
de relations et surtout ce capital
confiance qu'on ne peut obtenir cette
licence ragissime rarement donné par la
famille à un tel niveau effectivement
absolument c'est quand même exceptionnel
vite vite vite enfin la même famille
autour de la table ça veut pas dire
qu'on s'entend toujours bien vous parler
du capital confiance d'amitié un peu de
diplomatie au passage comment vous les
avez convaincu
on les a convaincus en leur moi je
dirais en respectant ce que ce qu'il a
culture d'entreprise de cette famille
est-ce que sont les valeurs de cette
famille cette famille c'est énormément
ce sont 8 artistes
quand on discute le modèle d'affaires
avec eux c'est un modèle de faire assez
particulier qui consiste à dire nous
sommes prêts à partager des droits avec
des gens qui vont assurer la pérennité
de l'oeuvre de notre père à condition
que le respect que les valeurs et
l'héritage de notre père a laissé au
monde or l'héritage de Charlie Chaplin
est un héritage de films extrêmement
courageux avec des contenus
forte dimension humaniste pacifiste
universaliste la dimension sociétale la
dimension humaniste de son oeuvre a été
au cœur de nos négociations on les a
convaincus en leur proposant une
positionnement d'offre de jeu qui allait
se démarquer par rapport à ce que
l'industrie des jeux vidéo offre dans le
monde historiquement
ce que vous allez faire avec l'image et
de Charlie Chaplin
on va essayer d'apporter un vent nouveau
un vent de fraîcheur dans l'industrie
des jeux vidéo en faisant des choses
autrement on sait que dans le passé les
jeux qui cartonnent à travers le monde
il y a quand même plus de 3 milliards de
joueurs dans le monde c'est un marché
qui est en expansion exceptionnelle les
jeux ont beaucoup grandi à cause de
positionnement d'offres ou de scénario
qui font souvent appel à ce que les
êtres humains ont de plus ville ou de
plus violents en eux nous on a proposé
la famille de s'inspirer des films et de
l'oeuvre de Trump qui est tout neuf fois
des mains humaniste en faisant des jeux
qui vont chercher ce que les êtres
humains ont de meilleurs en eux donc
dans nos jeux c'est pas le méchant qui
gagne dans nos jeux c'est c'est le petit
vagabond qui fait face au géant de ce
monde qui n'en ont que faire du sort des
plus petits et ça va intéresser le
public aujourd'hui
oui vous savez je vous dirais il y a une
tendance en affaires on dit il y a un
trade il y a une grande tendance dans le
monde dans un certain marché je dis pas
que c'est 100% du marché des gamers mais
il y a un fort potentiel de marché qui
est à la recherche de nouveaux types de
jeux puis de nouvelles façons de voir de
regarder le monde je vous dirai par
exemple que par exemple la communauté de
Chaplin de Parlement on parle de
dizaines de millions de fans loyaux sur
le site YouTube de la famille Chaplin on
reçoit 30 millions de vues par mois
c'est plus de 300 millions de vues par
année il y a un site en Inde où il y a
19 millions de fans et c'est ainsi de
suite à l'échelle des cinq continents et
cette communauté là elle a une
discographie une socio-démographique qui
est jeune ce sont pas des gens
nostalgiques du noir et blanc et des
films Dias 100 ans ce sont pour à plus
de 70% ce sont des gens d'entre 18 et 35
ans déjà les jeunes adultes qui adhèrent
à leur Chapel à cause de ses valeurs
humanitaires et sociétales très
intéressant puis avec des thèmes de
toute façon qui sont encore très très
contemporains et très très d'actualité
monsieur durant dites-nous tout nous
sommes entre nous combien coûte
l'exclusivité mondiale de l'image de
Charlie Chaplin
ce qui est intéressant avec la famille
quand on parle de modèle d'affaires
l'argent n'est pas le premier facteur et
sans donner de chiffres par respect pour
mes associés je vous dirais que c'est
pas les millions qu'on pense on est dans
l'ordre de centaines de mille on n'est
pas dans l'ordre de millions malgré la
dimension planétaire et exclusive et mes
véritablement exclusive de cette ce qui
a fait la différence c'est l'engagement
qu'on ne prie d'avoir un positionnement
d'oeuf qui allait être en congruence
avec ce qu'est l'héritage moral
l'héritage éthique l'héritage et
sociétales de l'oeuvre de Charlie
Chaplin les enfants parlent de leur père
les enfants ne veulent pas spolier
l'héritage de leur père et c'est ça que
fait la différence je vais même vous
dire que la famille nous a clairement
dit jamais on donnerait une telle
licence à une multinationale qui ne
pourrait pas nous garantir ce respect
éthique et moral ils ont donné à une
entreprise d'envergure moyenne
il y a un collectif d'entreprise
établi au Québec tous les jeux vidéo
avec qui vont mettre en vedette héros
qui est chargé dans la prochaine
décennie vont être conçus commercialiser
par des gens d'ici mais ils l'ont donné
une entreprise qui est une sorte de
coopérative de coopérative de collectif
de créateurs justement parce qu'on a une
dimension qui est qui est de l'envergure
de l'humanité qu'elles veulent c'est une
très belle histoire monsieur Durand et
c'est très intéressant puis on va vous
suivre on va vous regarder allez avec
Charlie Chaplin qui est toujours bien
vivant dans nos coeurs et dans notre
esprit merci à la prochaine bonne chance
merci beaucoup au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI